emmanuel macron arrive en tête aux
clayes-sous-bois avec un peu plus de 76%
des voix
marine le pen réalise l'un de ses
meilleurs scores sur saint quentin en
yvelines avec plus de 23 5% des
suffrages le candidat en marche a
bénéficié du report des voix notamment
avec une partie de l'électorat de
françois fillon et de jean luc mélenchon
il avait enregistré chacun un résultat
autour des 20% au premier tour cette
élection est particulière parce que je
pense que beaucoup de candidats certain
nombre de candidats qui ont voté par une
éviction n'est pas par conviction il y
en a qui se soit abstenue quand même
nationale dans la commune l'abstention
dépasse les 23 %
autre conséquence de ce rejet les votes
blancs ou nuls qui représente 10% des
votants et certains personnalisent leur
bulletin en souhaitant envoyer un
message ya de la colère il ya du
mécontentement il ya du désespoir aussi
il ya une défiance défiance vis-à-vis
des politiques
donc c'est pas du désintérêt je pense
que beaucoup de il ya beaucoup de
désespoir dans ce dans cette voie là
dans cette situation qu'on connaît
actuellement
prochain rendez vous électoral avec les
législatives les 11 et 18 juin prochain
un scrutin crucial pour former une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale